The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So I'm
going to describe
the basic classification of
solar cell characterization
methods.
And then I'll describe some
of the characterization tools
that are used to
measure Jsc losses
and other tools are used
to measure VOC and fill
factor losses.
So we're getting a sense
of the lay of the land.
Let me ask you how would you
characterize-- how would you
create a taxonomy of solar cell
characterization techniques?
Those of you might have a
little bit more experience
might actually have used a few
characterization techniques
in your laboratories.
What taxonomy would you use?
How would you slice the pie
of all these characterization
techniques?
Go.
What are ways to divide the
characterization universe
into distinct groupings?
How about we start-- go ahead.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Performance
and performance losses.
PROFESSOR: Yeah
so we can describe
based on the economic
variables like efficiency
and then within
efficiency Jsc, Voc,
fill factor, mechanical
yield, reliability.
These are all parameters that
can lump into a cost model
and ultimately impact the
cost-- dollars per watt,
let's say of a PV panel.
Excellent, so we can describe
it based on performance.
If we dive into
performance a little more,
what are some of the properties
that affect performance?
We have electrical properties,
optical properties, mechanical,
thermal.
So we can break up
characterization techniques
based on the properties
that they probe.
And we can also
characterize-- we
can create a taxonomy of
characterization techniques
based on how fast they
are, whether it's something
that you have to sit around and
twiddle your thumbs for a half
or two hours to get done
or something that gets done
in 10 milliseconds
of which there
are several
characterization techniques.
What would the 10 millisecond
variety enable you to do?
In a manufacturing environment?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sort them.
PROFESSOR: Sort them.
Test them.
Measure them-- every
single cell coming through.
So you might have
a bar code like one
of those fancy
two-dimensional bar codes
laser marked on each single
wafer going through your line
so you can trace it back in
your MES system all the way back
to the crystal that was grown
or from the thin film growth
chamber where it was deposited.
So, yes, you have
inline and shall
we say, the inline
characterization techniques
and what are called
offline characterization
techniques, which tend
to be lower throughput.
You can think of the inline
characterization techniques
as being in the line
of the manufacturing
environment and the offline
as being those techniques that
are sitting in your laboratory
waiting to be used in the R&D
lab, which might be next door
to the manufacturing line.
Device performance
metric affected--
that addresses the
efficiency point up here.
And then by property tested--
electrical, structural,
optical, mechanical.
So if you talk to somebody
who works in a PV company,
she will likely give
you a break down
based on number
three right here.
OK, these are the techniques
that we have in our inspection
system and those are
the techniques that I
have over there in the R&D lab.
If you talk to somebody who
is giving a fundamental course
in materials science, they
are likely to pick part number
one way up there and give
you the breakdown based
on the properties
that are probed.
I'm going to opt for
number two today in lecture
not because it's any better
or worse than all the others,
but just because that's
the metric that we care
about right now as we're trying
to probe dollars per watt that
relates to our quiz
and our homework,
but also relates to the ultimate
economic driver of solar.
So we will keep
this in mind that we
might need to ferret
out references
for the different techniques
in different textbooks
or different papers based
on whether they're probing
electrical structural
optical mechanical properties
of our solar cells.
But we're going to be
focused on efficiency--
short circuit, current, open
circuit, voltage, fill factor.
So let's go ahead
and dive into that.
We are going to first
start with techniques
to measure Jsc or short
circuit current losses.
And some of these slides
are going to be repeats.
And the reason
they're repeats is
because the first time you
saw it OK, you sort of kind of
got it.
You went to the lab, made
your devices, tested them.
And now all of a sudden, you
have a much stronger background
with which to understand.
We're going to
start by discussing
the optical components
just very briefly
and then spectra response and
minority carrier diffusion
length, revisiting
some of these concepts
that we have already
seen, but now
with the benefit of having all
of our background knowledge.
The spectrophotometer
measures specular and diffuse
reflectance and transmission.
All right, let's
break that down.
Specular reflectance--
specu lar-- Latin.
So specular reflectance
means light comes in and out
pretty much at the same angle
relative to the surface normal.
So if you come in
from here, it's
going to bounce out light
there right at the same angle
relative to the surface normal.
Diffuse reflectance
means that if you
shine light in a
certain angle, it's
going to reflect back not
necessarily at that angle.
You could have a distribution.
A Lambertian scatterer
might qualify.
And reflectance
in transmission--
we talked about different
optical losses of a solar cell
material.
Reflectance means that light
comes back off the surface.
Transmission means that
light did not get absorbed.
So it went through the material
and didn't get absorbed.
That is an optical loss as well.
So the spectrophotometer
is useful for measuring
these different loss mechanisms.
And it can tease
apart the specular
from the diffuse
reflectance, giving you
some indication, some idea,
of how the surface is behaving
and what you might
do to improve it.
So the spectrophotometer
is useful in that regard.
In terms of
increasing absorption,
we talked about various
methods to increase absorption.
Those who attended Eli
Yablonovitch's talk
heard about many more.
The goal here is essentially
to increase the optical path
length by texturing your
surface, for instance.
The physical thickness
can remain very low.
And, again, just to
refresh ourselves
if we decrease the
thickness of our devices
but manage to have very
good like trapping,
what happens to our
excess carrier density?
It goes up, right?
Because now we
have more carriers
being generated in
a smaller volume
so the carrier
density increases.
And as the carry
density goes up,
that means the separation of the
quasi-Fermi energies increases,
which means the maximum voltage
extractable from or devices
increases as well.
So there's a strong
push right now
in the field to go thinner
and thinner devices.
That also has the added
benefit economically
of using less material.
So we want to
decrease the thickness
by improving our optical
trapping-- our light trapping.
Another benefit is it allows
carriers to be absorbed closer
to the junction, which increases
the probability of collection.
And we talked about this during
the very beginning of class
how you might
texture your surface.
But now we actually saw
it in producing our cells.
So this is an example-- an SCM
image-- of textured silicon.
In that particular case,
this was an alkali etch
on a single crystalline
sample probably of 1 0
0 orientation so that these
edges of the pyramids are 1 1
1 planes.
You could also
achieve a similar,
although not identically,
looking result
if you have performed
an acidic etch, which
would be isotropic in nature.
So the light comes in
for the textured surface.
Some of it goes into the device.
Notice that Snell's
law is in effect.
So the light bent
or was refracted.
And some of the light is
reflected off the surface.
Now, because of
the texturization,
you get that
second-chance absorption.
So the light has two
bounces before leaving,
which means that the probability
of the light getting absorbed
is 1 minus r quantity squared.
And so you get an
enhanced absorption.
And for those who
looked at the samples
before and after
texturization, you
could visibly see that
they looked darker--
the reflectivity had gone down.
I see some smiles over here.
There are probably some
initial etching processes
that didn't quite work out,
but eventually the process
was controlled and
worked out fine.
So we have as well
other mechanisms
to trap the light besides just
texturing our front surface.
These we didn't get to
do an actual cell fab.
But we could envision putting
a reflective or defuse scatter
on the back and
reflective layer so
that the light that goes all
the way through the material
once gets bounced back
in perhaps at an angle
to increase the
trapping in the back.
And that I think is represented
on the previous slide.
It is indeed.
So we have a textured
back surface.
And we also have this layer--
probably in this case,
it would most likely be
a dielectric material
with the refractive index
that is significantly
different than the
absorber itself.
So if your absorber
material is an organic,
you might have a
refractive index
somewhere between 1.5 and
2 maybe on the high end.
And if you have an
inorganic material,
you could have refractive
indices as high as 3, 3.5.
And the material
you put in the back
would probably be as close
as you could possibly
get to air to get as
a large reflection
off the back as possible.
In the case of silicon
devices, oftentimes you
have a dielectric material
with a refractive index
somewhere between 1.5 and 2.
And that serves also to
passivate the surface
to prevent carriers from
recombining in the back side.
So a collection probability--
we talked about this earlier now
that we've performed
quantum efficiency
and we've tested
our own devices,
I'm going to walk
through it again.
It's an important
concept to really grasp.
I want to make sure
that everybody got it.
We have here a p-n junction.
Here's our P-type material.
Here's our N-type material.
Shown at the blue little
dots-- those are our holes--
free holes-- mobile holes able
to move around the material.
And on the n-type side,
we have here the red dots.
Those are also free to
move around the materials.
Those are electron--
negative charged carriers.
Omitted from this diagram--
omitted from this diagram
is the fixed charge associated
with each connectivity type.
We have, for example,
fixed negative charge
from the ionized
acceptors and the p-type
and fixed positive charge
from the ionized donors.
And the n-type-- we've
omitted it for clarity.
We note that an electric
field builds up here
at the junction between.
And that sweeps carriers
into one side or another
so that if light comes in and
generates a pair of charges--
due to charge
neutrality, it generates
a pair-- a positive and
a negative-- the charge
carrier type will be
swept across the junction
and the other will remain
inside of the material.
And so to be more precise
about the exact motion that
occurs with the carriers,
we have at first a diffusion
process until the electric field
starts becoming large and then
finally drift across
that junction.
And that's what generates the
current inside of a solar cell
device.
So collection
probability means that
light-- a light-generated--
a photo-generated minority
carrier can readily recombine.
But if the carrier reaches
the edge of the space charge
region, the minority carrier can
be swept across and collected.
So the probability of collection
means for every electron hole
pair that I generate at
a certain depth, what
is the probability that the
minority carrier will make it
across a junction.
And this is what we're
probing in spectral response.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How long is the
exciton diffusion in silicon?
PROFESSOR: Great question.
The exciton in silicon has a
binding energy less than kt,
which means at room
temperature, the exciton
readily dissociates.
So the exciton diffusion
length can only
be measured at
lower temperatures.
At room temperature,
you essentially
just discuss minority carriers.
And the minority carrier
diffusion length--
let's revert it in
terms of lifetime
and then do the translation
to diffusion length.
In terms of lifetimes,
one typically
has a range between
a microsecond
to a millisecond-- millisecond
being on the high end.
It can go as high as
five milliseconds even.
And so if you revert that
into a diffusion length,
one microsecond lifetime
would correspond
to a 50-micron diffusion length.
And then you can do the
rest of the conversion
from there just taking the
square root sign into account.
So it can be rather long on
the order of the thickness
of the solar cell devices.
Now those length skills, which
we were talking about hundreds
of microns-- maybe even
a thousand microns.
Compare that now to
10-nanometer diffusion length
say for an exciton in a
polymer blend material.
Then you have to reconsider
your device architecture.
And how you're going to
actually collect them.
So this is a very
generic picture, which
could easily be substituted.
Instead of n-type, p-type, it
could be easily substituted
by say polymer 1 and polymer 2
that just have the right band
alignment to separate charge.
Then it gets a little
more complicated as well.
Here we're assuming
that the carriers that
are swept across the
junction can move
easily away from the junction.
In a polymer, not always so.
You might have charge
accumulation right
at the edge of the space
charge region, which
creates its own field,
which counteracts
the built-in field here and
also inhibits current flow.
So things get a lot
more complicated
as you venture away from
the simple case of say
a well-behaved
what it was called
in this case a homo junction,
meaning a p-n junction created
from the same material
on both sides-- silicon
just n-type an p-type.
If you have a hetero
junction comprised
of two different
materials, you may have
additional effects occurring.
But it's always helpful to think
about the motion of carriers
from the perspective
of drift and diffusion.
And if you're ever in doubt,
you can begin thinking about
the process in terms of delta
T's-- small increments of time
where you imagine light coming
in generating an electron hole
pair, imagining what happens
as that carrier moves
to the junction then
moves across the junction.
And then what happens?
Does it immediately
get collected?
Does it stay there?
What happens next?
Is there a potential--
an attractive potential
between the carriers on
either side of that junction.
So asking those
sorts of questions
can help you walk through and
troubleshoot what exactly is
going wrong with your device.
Collection probability--
so we take this diagram
that we just on the previous
slide-- this one right here.
And we say, if light were
to come in and generate
an electron hole
pair right here,
then I would expect very high
probability of collection,
meaning the minority carrier
would be swept across.
The majority carrier
would stay on this side.
And presuming that they can
get from here to the contacts--
big assumption-- but
assuming that they
can-- then the probability of
collection of those carries
will be very, very high.
But if my light comes in
deep within the device
and generates an
electron hole pair,
the minority carrier will
have to cruise through-- you
can think about it.
It may be a nice, tasty chicken
in the Everglades National
Park trying to make its
way over from that side
all the way over to the
junction and across.
The minority carrier is
at risk of recombining.
And many of them don't make it.
So we have the following graph--
the collection probability
versus distance into the
device where this yellow region
represents the space charge
region-- where the probability
of collection is very high.
And as you move away from
the space charge region,
the probability of
collection decreases.
And you can see it
decreases exponentially
as a function of distance
from the space charge region.
The reason you have almost--
not exactly symmetric--
these are two different
decay constants,
but they're both exponential
functions on either side--
is because over here on what
ostensibly would be the-- what
did we call it--
the p-type side--
the electrons would be
the minority carriers.
And over the n-type
side, the holes
are the minority carriers.
And each one is trying
to get to the other side.
So the collection
probability is actually
the collection probability
of minority carriers--
the precise
definition of which is
changing from one side of
the junction to the other.
On one side of the
junction, the electrons
are the minority carriers.
And on the other side, the
holes are the minority carriers.
So by probing at different
wavelengths of light,
we essentially change the
optical absorption coefficient
of the material, which means
that the light will get
absorbed at different depths.
So we might have a very short
wavelength light that probes
up here.
And then, say light is
coming in from this side--
so short wavelengths
light gets absorbed
near the front surface.
And then longer, longer,
longer, and longer, and longer
wavelengths until we're
deep within the material.
And we can flush out exactly
what the current collection
probability would be
as a function of depth.
Then we essentially
take that data
knowing the generation rate
and the collection probability.
We can tease out the minority
carrier diffusion length
using the spectrophotometer.
So let me show you examples
of good and bad cells.
This would be a bad solar cell
and a good solar cell device
right over here.
The good solar cell has a high
internal quantum efficiency
out to longer wavelengths.
And as we know from the very
second lecture of our class,
the longer wavelengths
get absorbed
deeper into the device
further from the junction.
And so you can see this
tail off occurring.
Actually, the tail off is
somewhere in this region
right here for this device
is occurring within the bulk.
At some point, the device
just isn't thick enough
to absorb all the light.
So there is an inevitable drop
toward longer wavelengths.
But the bad cell doesn't
an even poorer job
of collecting these
longer wavelengths.
And that's in part because
the minority carrier diffusion
length of that particular
cell was much lower
or save the minority
carrier diffusion length
of the material which
comprise the cell is
much lower than the good cell.
So if you come in with a
longer wavelength for light--
let's say maybe 933
nanometers in silicon
that would give an absorption
depth of around 100 microns--
that's pretty far
from the junction--
now you would have a much lower
probability in the bad cell
of collecting than
the good cell.
And that's precisely because
the diffusion length is lower.
So integrated over all
of the wavelengths,
one obtains the
short-circuit current.
And the method of measurement
was the spectrophotometer.
Now, I understand
most of you opted
to choose Sun's Voc for your
one characterization tool
to apply to your cells.
Did anybody choose
a spectrophotometer?
Show of hands.
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: It was broken.
PROFESSOR: It was broken, yeah,
so the filter wheel was down.
That was it.
So let's see, the filter
wheel-- the filter wheel.
Let's go fixing this.
Here it is.
So the filter wheel was broken.
So essentially, the
polychromatic light source
was shining through a filter
wheel which was selecting
one wavelength of light.
The monochrometer,
of course, was
helping as well and eventually
on to the solar cell
sample, which was shown
in front of the light.
So that's the way in principle
spectral response works.
And one variant of
spectral response--
that's for the full device.
You typically have
an illuminated area
of a few millimeters squared
or maybe even a few centimeters
squared.
But let's say that wasn't
good enough for you.
You knew you had an
inhomogeneous material
and you want to probe
the inhomogeneity
across your device.
You had a large
device maybe about
that big-- a few 10s
of centimeters squared.
And you want to probe
the distribution
of minority carrier diffusion
lengths across your device.
How would you do that?
Well, in one incarnation,
you would use a much more
finely-focused beam.
Instead of having something
on the order of a millimeter,
you might shrink the
beam spot size down
to the range of single microns.
And then use an xy stepper motor
to scan across your device.
And that's precisely what
this does right here.
This white piece
is the xy stage.
And this black head
right here is essentially
comprised of several lasers that
will shine on to the sample.
Now, you need a few different
wavelengths of light
to really flesh out this curve
to determine the minority
carrier diffusion
length from this curve.
And so the laser light
is typically chosen
at very auspicious wavelengths
to maximize utility
in this particular
type of evaluation.
And so we have usually
four-- a minimum three.
You can always fit a
line through two data
points-- so a minimum three
laser wavelengths and usually
about four or more to process
the quantum efficiency
as a function of position.
And so the xy stage moves the
sample around and the laser
head-- or moves the
laser head around
while the sample stays
fixed and you map out
the current response at
each point on the device,
obtaining a map that
looks much like this right
here where this is on the y
scale or the z scale, sorry,
you have from 0 to
120-micron diffusion length
on that particular
solar cell device.
And points 3, 1, and 2 represent
regions in which the minority
carrier diffusion
with was calculated
using the method that we have
discussed in the previous
lectures-- the
Paul Basore method.
So we have a map of
minority carrier diffusion
length across our device.
Some regions are
underperforming.
Other regions are
performing rather well.
And we can see that in general,
these lower-cost materials
tend to be fairly inhomogeneous
in terms of their performance
response.
And if you really want
to get fancy and say,
my goodness, if I spend all
this time mapping my device,
I'm not going to get through
many devices during my Ph.D.
I'm going tour have to make
do with very poor statistics.
How do I speed this up?
Some very clever
people have figured out
that if you fire your
laser diode simultaneously
but with different
frequencies-- each of them
with its own frequency--
you can deconvolute
the current response
of your device
using a Fourier transform to
pick out the current response
at each portion of the frequency
space-- in other words,
decouple the different
wavelengths of light.
So it's a little clever method
involving Fourier transforms
and lock-in method to speed up
the measurement a little bit--
small aisde-- small
footnote there.
Important-- minority
carrier diffusion length.
That's of utmost importance.
So we can relate the
diffusion length directly back
to our IV curve via the
saturation current-- via the J
nought or I nought, depending
on whether you're looking
at density or absolute amount.
Let's shift gears a bit.
I want to talk about
the Voc measurements
and fill factor
loss measurements.
So how do you determine
losses in Voc and fill factor?
Before I jump into
this, does anybody
have any questions about
Jsc loss mechanisms?
So sad that the
spectrophotometer
wasn't up and running.
Sniff.
It should be fixed
relatively soon, right Joe?
It's fixed now?
All right.
So we have I think David Berney
Needleman is back on board,
right?
AUDIENCE: Rupac is.
PROFESSOR: Rupac as well, yeah.
So if we have folks
who still want
to measure their devices using
spectrophotometer measurement,
we can probably
make arrangements
for say what, 10
cells to be measured?
Something in that range?
AUDIENCE: There were
only three people
who want to do it originally.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's
fit them in-- the three
people who wanted to do them.
And we'll have
our full data set.
Good.
So let's describe fill
factor and VOC losses.
And this is venturing
into operating conditions.
Under short circuit
conditions, how much power
is running through
the solar cell device?
Power defined as
current voltage product.
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero, why is that?
AUDIENCE: No voltage.
PROFESSOR: No voltage, right?
So you're not testing your
solar cell under ideal operating
conditions.
It's an artificial
operating condition simply
to probe a bulk property
characteristics-- to minimize
the effect of the junction.
Now, if you really
want to see how does
is the junction behaving-- how
that charge separation going--
you might want to venture
into forward bias conditions
and eventually into open
circuit voltage conditions
to really test what the junction
quality is instead of just
probing bulk properties.
So let's talk about some of
the measurement techniques
to really get to the heart of
how are solar cells performing.
It's helpful to do
the Jsc measurements.
It helps you predict what might
be some of the loss mechanisms
later on.
But for this really
gets at the meat of it.
IV curve measurements-- check.
We studied that.
We did that in the laboratory.
And I think we have
a pretty good sense
of what's going on there now.
Series resistance losses-- we
talked earlier in the class
about context and sheet
resistance losses.
Now we'll go back
to it again just
to revisit so we have the
materials necessary to write up
the report here on this project.
Shunt resistance-- specifically
in shunt resistance
we'll talk about
lock-in thermography
and electroluminescence.
And finally, we'll have
a small slide on Suns-Voc
and talk about that
as well since I
know the majority
of you selected that
as your measurement tool.
All right, so open
circuit voltage--
reading straight
off the slide here.
"If the collected
light-generated carriers
are not extracted in the solar
cell, but instead remain,
then a charge separation
exists across,
meaning there's a
buildup of charge.
And the charge separation
reduces the electric field
in the depletion
region, which reduces
the barrier to diffusion
current and causes the diffusion
current to flow.
In words, if you have light
coming into your device,
but you're not able to extract
the charges from either side
to make sure that the
chemical potential is
equal on both sides,
the chemical potential
will change on either side.
You'll have a
buildup of one charge
type on one side of the
junction and build up
of the opposite charge type on
the other side of the junction.
And so that will
shift the Fermi energy
on the other side
of the junction
and result in a
bias of your device
and eventually counteract
the built-in electric field
to the point where the diffusion
current is now enabled to flow.
All this sounding
familiar to folks.
It might be a little rusty.
But it's this all there.
So the idea now is to
begin probing that junction
condition.
We talked about the
ideal diode equation.
And now we're going to
piece through it once again.
This is your current
density here.
And I believe if you really
want to be precise about this,
you should use straight
current and not
current density--
the reason being
if you look at current
resistance product, that
gives you voltage.
But current density
resistance product
gives you essentially
a voltage density,
which is not a unit
that we typically use.
So just keep that in mind
as a small, little asterisk.
This equation is
often used in PV.
That little unit conversion
issue is generally ignored,
but you might want to flag
it for your own benefit.
So we have the current
output of our device
as a function of voltage.
And this is a rather complicated
expression going well
beyond the ideal
diode equation--
the ideal diode equation, which
would consist of the J sub L--
the illumination current.
This is the light coming in
creating the carriers that are
then swept across the junction .
The J sub L is going to
be the integral current
under a spectral response curve
at each wavelength weighted
for the wave length of the
incoming light or the intensity
at that particular bandwidth
of the incoming light.
Figure it this way.
You're measuring the
spectral response
at each particular
wavelength. what
the collection probability is.
Then if you multiply by
the total number of photons
in that wavelength range, you're
determining the total number
of carriers generated within
that frequency range of light.
And if you add up
all the little bins,
you get all of the carriers
generated by all of the light.
And you can adjust depending
what spectral conditions
you have-- say 8.15 spectrum.
So the J sub L here-- this one,
is our short circuit current
effectively and what is derived
from a spectral response
measurement.
The rest of these terms
here are of interest.
So the J-- let's break
down into pieces here.
This term over
here is essentially
to take into account
shunt resistance losses.
If we have shunts
in our device, we're
going to be reducing
the total power output.
These two components--
what are usually
called diffusion current
and recombination current--
this one, you have to
take me for my word at it
right now-- this is the
recombination within the space
charge region.
And this over here
is a recombination
within the bulk
of the solar cell.
Here's a good way
to think about it.
If our solar cell is
not forward biased--
if it's very, very slightly
forward biased-- just
a little bit-- there's going to
be a large barrier for majority
carriers one side the junction
to overcome-- to drive
a drift current--
sorry, diffusion
current-- a very large
barrier to overcome.
And hence, the
recombination is most
likely to occur within
the space charge region.
The carriers aren't likely
to overcome that barrier,
get into the bulk,
and recombine there.
Whereas if we are under large
forward bias conditions,
now the carriers can very
easily go over that barrier
and recombine in the bulk.
So this term right
here dominates
under low forward-bias
conditions.
And this term over here
dominates under larger forward
bias conditions.
And that's why you see when
you plot your IV curve on log
linear scale, you see
essentially two flat points
on your IV curve.
Let me forward that to
the next slide right here.
So this is log of current
versus linear voltage.
And you see one flat
portion right here
and another flat
before the series resistance
begins to dominate
at too high voltage.
And your shunt resistance
dominates at too low voltage.
This flat portion right there
is being driven by recombination
within the space charge region.
Why?
Well, the forward
bias voltage isn't
enough to really lower
that barrier enough
to allow the carriers deep
within the bulk to recombine.
So the carriers are recombining
in the space charge region.
Whereas here, they are
recombining within the bulk.
So this is a more
complicated expression
for the IV characteristics
of a solar cell device.
Not always are these
precise mechanisms at work.
If you have a new material
system that you're
working with, there might
be different re combination
mechanisms at work.
There might be charged
accumulation effects at work.
But they can all be encapsulated
in some form of current voltage
expression.
Think of the IV characteristics
of the solar cell
similar to say the
constitutive relations
of a complex
viscoelastic material
where you have say a nice,
linear elastic component,
a dashpot component.
So you have a very
complex expression
describing the stress-strain
relationship in the material.
A similar thing goes on
here with the solar cell
where you're describing the
current voltage relationship
if you understand all of
the mechanisms driving
carrier recombination in your
material and charge separation.
You can come up
with an expression
that describes very precisely
the IV characteristics.
But if you change
material systems,
you may not necessarily be able
to transition the same models
over.
It's helpful to start with them.
But sooner or later you
might decide, well, gee,
I have to make
some modifications.
All right, OK,
series resistance--
we already studied this before,
but just a quick refresher.
We have the series
resistance of the bulk.
resistance of the emitter.
And then we have the series
resistance of the contacts
as we contact the
device and then
the series resistance
within the contact itself.
So at least four different
components of series resistance
in our device that are all
lumped together when we
express our IV curve
in this manner.
We all lump them together
in that R sub S. Question?
AUDIENCE: Without going
through the math, is there
a simple explanation
where the 2 comes from?
PROFESSOR: Yeah so simple
explanation, if you would like,
is mostly where the Fermi
energy is sitting relative
to the conduction
or valence band.
And the space charge region--
the quasi neutral region
is closer to mid gap as
opposed to closer to bandage.
Hand wavy-- if you really
want to get into it,
I spent about three
months studying
this as a graduate student.
The 1 and the 2--
the ideality factor,
which is to show more precisely.
It's the number that comes
before the kT for each
of these.
That's called the
ideality factor.
It typically expresses
N sub 1 or N sub 2.
In this case I just substituted
straight out for a 1 and a 2.
Those numbers aren't
always 1 and 2.
As a matter of fact,
especially the G nought 1--
the bulk recombination
current, depending
on where the defect
levels lie, it
can be somewhere between
say 1.1 and 1.4 typically.
And beautiful thesis work
done by a fellow in Australia
hold on-- Keith McIntosh
And the title of the thesis
is called "Humps,
Bumps, and Lumps."
It's all about non idealities
within an IV curve.
So if you're really
curious about that,
"Humps, Bumps, and
Lumps," by McIntosh
I believe was the name.
So we talked about series
resistance already.
Hold that-- put
that in your RAM.
That's our R sub
S right over here.
S. And our shunt--
you want to hold this other
component in your RAM.
So that's the picture
to have of our series.
This is our shunt.
This is a p-n junction.
This is your n plus region.
And this is your p.
And this is looking at
the electron energy in 3D.
So we typically take a slice
out like that just like this.
And we draw the electron
energy as a function
of position in a
nice little wavy form
that we typically do to
describe the p-n junction.
What's being
described right here
is adding a leader dimension--
a spatial dimension in what's
shown as the
abscissa in this plot
and showing what is a
weakness in the p-n junction.
It could be a localized defect.
This could be a
shard of metal that
happened to lie in the wrong
place in your device and fire
through, essentially
when you did the firing
step to adhere the metal
to create the contact.
It could have gone straight
through the p-n junction
and contacted the other side.
It could be a
charged dislocation.
It could be structural
defect, but a local reduction
in the barrier height.
Now where is the electron going
to go if you have a diffusion
current?
It's going to be crowding
through that little,
localized, reduction
in the energy barrier.
And you're going to have
a higher current flowing
through the specific region.
So how to measure that?
Well, if I make sure my
full IV curve like this,
it might manifest itself as
some reduced shunt resistance.
So you'll have a larger
current flowing through it
at lower bias voltages.
But how do I know
what's going on?
Without some spatial-- a
spatially-resolved measurement
tool, I am in the
dark-- no pun intended.
So I have to figure out how
to measure the current flow
as a function of position.
Now somebody thought
about this a while.
And they said, ha, well,
let me get this straight.
If I apply a known bias
voltage to my device,
I'm going to get some
current flowing through it.
And that current-- what I
read out of the whole device
microscopically has some
spatial distribution to it.
Let me think about this.
OK, so current times
voltage is power.
And power generates heat.
So if I have a current crowding
at some portion of my device,
I'm going to be generating
a large amount of heat
as the carriers flow through
that specific region.
So if I have some
method of measuring
the heat-- the heat
distribution across my device
is very, very sensitive--
I might be able to divide
that heat measurement--
if calibrated properly
to determine total
power-- I might
be able to divide that
heat measurement by voltage
so I know the applied
bias voltage to my device.
I take my power, divide
it by the voltage,
and I get the current as
a function of xy position.
So I can map out my dark IV
curve at any arbitrary bias
voltage condition.
Let's say I want to do
the measurement at 0.4
volts forward bias.
I apply 0.4 volts
across my device.
And I just measure
the heat distribution.
And in the calibrated
measurement,
you can see how
the dark current is
distributed-- how the diffusion
current is distributed.
And that's what lock-in
thermography is all about.
This is a somewhat
typical image.
It's still very noisy because
it was a very fast image.
But you have here a
solar cell device.
You can barely make out the
contact grid right here.
And then the fingers
are moving down
separated by about this much.
On this particular
image, you can
see the fingers or the
dark shadow of the fingers
right here.
And you see bright
spots 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7 across the device,
indicating regions
where more current is flowing.
Aha!
So I'm beginning to
figure out that, well,
this dark IV curve that
I have right here--
this large amount of current
flowing through my device
at lower bias voltages.
That's not all
uniformly distributed.
But it's rather concentrated
in specific areas
where I have weaknesses
in my p-n junction
under low forward bias voltages.
And then at larger
forward bias voltages
once this barrier is
significantly reduced,
I may have more carriers
going through in regions
of smaller minority
carrier diffusion length.
Why?
Well, because if the carrier
goes in and recombines quickly
because the diffusion
length is very short,
that means there's one
less carrier in there,
which means that now
there's a greater driving
force for diffusion.
And another care
is going to come in
and recombine too and another
carrier and recombine too.
And so now you have a
larger diffusion current
going into the regions of lower
minority carrier diffusion
length.
Let's look at a few
lock-in thermography images
and see how this plays out.
So under low-bias conditions--
so I'm still-- still
have a very large barrier there
in the p-n junction region.
I'm typically going to see
isolated hot spots-- not
always, but typically
isolated hot spots.
And these most often are
defects within the p-n junction.
Somebody must have
scratched the junction
or maybe dropped their tweezer
on it or maybe a piece of metal
during the contact
metalization fired through
at that particular region.
And so we have what are
typically these point shunts.
Sometimes you see
shunts around the edge
as well if you didn't
isolate the edge well.
And now as we forward bias,
forward bias, forward bias,
those barriers become
less important.
And now what's driving the
current-- the dark current
in the device is a
recombination of the bulk.
So the regions of
higher recombination
will be regions of
higher current flow.
They'll drive more
recombination current.
So this is a higher bias
voltage-- 560 millivolts
or 0.56 volts as
opposed to 0.36 volts.
We can still see the shadow
of the big three right here.
But they're much diminished.
Now instead what we see
are these wispier features
right here.
Now I think gee, if that
really is-- if those really
are regions of lower minority
carrier diffusion length--
I just learned about a methods
to measure minority carrier
diffusion length, didn't I?
What was that?
Laser beam induced
current method?
Spatially-resolved laser
beam in this current?
So I have at least one method
of measuring minority carrier
diffusion length.
Let's put one and one
together and see what we get.
So we'll take this
image right here
and put it aside,
rotate it, and put it
right beside the minority
carrier diffusion length.
And voila, you see how
those wispier features
are corresponding to regions
of lower minority carrier
diffusion length-- once
again, the explanation.
If you have large
forward bias condition,
the barrier is lower.
Carriers can easily
diffuse into the bulk.
The carriers defusing
into the bulk
will go a certain distance
before recombining.
If the diffusion
length is short,
they'll recombine
quickly, which means
now there's no more carrier--
which means the diffusion
current will push another
carrier into that spot, which
means they'll recombine.
More current is flowing
through if the diffusion
length is shorter.
The alternative is if the
diffusion length is long
and one carrier makes
it over and then takes
its time getting
all the way across
before recombination occurs.
So what you're seeing
here is essentially
an effect-- the current
the dark, forward current,
meaning you're measuring
the IV curve in the dark.
You're obtaining an IV curve.
Here it is.
You're obtaining an IV
curve for your device.
You're measuring in the dark
under larger forward bias
conditions somewhere around
here where bulk recombination is
dominating.
And you're able to
visualize the current loss
mechanisms in your device.
So you say, well, gee
if I want in the dark--
if I want this to be
as small as possible
so that when I transpose
this in the light
and I shift everything into
negative-- into fourth quadrant
territory because I illuminate
it now-- if I want there to be
a small, dark forward
current as possible
so as I maximize my fill factor
when I illuminate my device,
I want all of these current
loss mechanisms to go away.
Let me repeat that one
more time so people get it.
So what I'm doing right
now is I'm measuring
this device in the dark.
And this is my IV
curve right here.
And I have an example of
bad device-- good device.
The bad device has--
so bad and good.
The reason this
is bad and good is
because when I transpose this
curve under illumination--
this is now under illumination--
my good and bad right here--
you'll see that the
bad has a lower Voc.
So the intersection
between these illuminated
curves-- this is
now illuminated.
And this is dark.
Right over here--
these are dark curves.
These here are
illuminated curves.
The intersection between
the illuminated curve
and the x-axis denotes
the open circuit voltage.
And you see that the larger
this current is in the dark
the earlier you're going to
intersect with your x-axis--
the lower the voltage output of
your device will be-- the lower
the maximum power point will be.
So want in the dark when
you measure the IV curve,
you want that current to be as
small as possible in the dark.
And, obviously, when
you illuminate it,
you want this jump to
be as large as possible.
And you want this to
almost look like a box
to have a large fill factor.
So if we say, OK, we
want this to be small
because we want a
large fill factor,
somehow we have to know
where the current loss
mechanisms are occurring.
And that's where we have lock-in
thermography available to us
we can visualize it.
You say, well, to do
lock-in thermography well,
I'm going to need an-- indium
antimonide-- sorry, yeah that
would be it.
It would be an indium antimonide
camera sensitive to the 3 to 5
micron wavelength
range that might
cost $70,000 to get a good
one with high frame rates.
The lock-in system-- I don't
know if I have that money.
I can go over and borrow
Professor Buonassisi's system
and use it there.
Or if my shunts
are big enough, I
can just use straight-out
thermionic sheets
or thermochromic
sheets, rather, sorry.
So you can take
these liquid crystals
and slap them
because your device
and measure the heat
distribution straight up just
by making sure you have
good thermal contact
between your cell and your
thermochromic sheets, which
cost about $100.
Now the reason we use the
lock-in thermogrpahy and not
these thermochromic sheets
is this curve right here.
This is lock-in
thermography sensitivity
versus integration time.
And we're getting into
the 10 microKelvin range,
which is rattlesnake territory.
That's how the rattlesnakes are
able to sense heat and reach
out to you is because they
have those little organs that
look like little, black--
they're integrating spheres
to be honest-- small,
little spot to open up.
Rattlesnake-- that's why
the sidewinder missile.
Anybody?
F 16s?
Hornets?
No.
If you're into aviation,
there's a special type
of heat seeking
missile developed
I think in the 1950s
that uses a device not
dissimilar from the rattlesnakes
heat sensing organs.
Regardless, I
digress, we're looking
at about a 10
microKelvin sensitivity
in this lock-in thermography
technique, which
is very sensitive-- can
measure under low forward bias
conditions and hence useful.
So that pretty much sums
up lock-in thermography.
It is a difficult technique
to wrap your brain around.
So for those of you who got
75% of it, congratulations.
That was really,
really well done.
For those who got about
25% of my explanations
today, don't worry.
You're not alone.
It just takes a
lot of thinking it
through exactly where is the
current flowing as a function
of bias condition?
What does that do
to my IV curve?
And then what does it do
in a two-dimensional regime
when I'm measuring heat output?
It's is a very
complicated thing.
Thankfully there is an entire
book lock-in thermography
written by Otwin Breitenstein.
I gave to you today
a paper-- in one
of the papers that I
distributed today--
the one that has the PSSA
written on it-- this one.
That paper is by
Otwin Breitenstein
from the Max Planck Institute
of Microstructure Physics
in Halle, Germany about two
a half and a half hours south
of Berlin.
And this describes in more
detail that which I attempted
to get across in class today.
He with Martin
Langenkamp have also
written a book on
lock-in thermography.
So if you're interested
in more information,
that's where to go.
In your handout
set today, we also
have a classic paper on
series resistance effects
of solar cell measurements.
This one is from
'63-- yes, 1963.
Classic paper worth
the read if you're
in that regime
making devices that
are series resistance limited.
It's more optional
reading for folks.
And let's venture forward.
Folks who did these scanning
Elbit techniques for a while
really found value in
measuring as a function
of spatially-resolved
manner down
to a micron in
spatial resolution
the electrical output
of a solar cell device.
And then they thought
to themselves, well,
goodness, if we measure
with one micron spot size,
it's going to take
us a week to get
a measurement across a full area
solar device, if not longer.
And if we measure say
with the 200 nanometer
spot size using some
sort of X-ray technique
and we accumulate for
say two seconds a point,
it can take 10,000 years to
map out a full-size solar cell
device, literally, do the math.
And they said is there
an easier way for us
to acquire information that does
not rely on scanning-- on point
by point, step by
step measurements.
And they thought about it
long and hard they said, well,
gee, these new, handheld,
digital cameras coming out
on the market are pretty cool.
What technology do they rely on?
Oh, it's a CCD-- Charge
Couple Display that visualizes
or images over a large area
the output of a device.
And that's exactly how the
lock-in thermography techniques
were developed here with this
imaging camera-- in that case,
an indium antimonice CCD.
And they said, well,
what other wavelengths
emit-- in what other wavelength
does a solar cell emit?
We know that it emits heat.
And heat is typically in the 3
to 5 micron wavelengths regime,
maybe even as high as 10 microns
depending on what temperature.
And we know that as well we
can have band to band emission
inside of a solar cell that
would emit around the band gap
energy.
So let's set up
a camera to image
the band-to-band
recombination intensity
or the band-to-band
illumination intensity.
And that's what
this paper is about.
This is wavelength.
This is intensity.
This is the emission
spectrum of a solar cell.
So if you were to measure what
colors-- what color light does
a solar cell emit after
you pump current into it,
this isn't is more
or less the spectrum.
So we have the thermal
radiation shown over here.
This is longer wavelength light.
That's the heat
that it gives off.
That's what indicates current
flow inside of the device.
There is the band to band
luminescence right here.
And we'll neglect the
other two for now.
Those are more
advanced concepts.
But the band to
band luminescence
is essentially just
the recombination
of a carrier from
the conduction band
to the valence band--
recombination--
very straightforward.
And the recombination
intensity is inversely
proportional to the
minority carrier lifetime.
Why is that?
This was that quote remember
who attended Eli Yablonovich's
talk.
He was saying, it's
completely counter intuitive.
Do you remember
specifically what
he was referring to in this?
Let me show you an image here.
AUDIENCE: That you
want your device
to emit more light for
higher device performance.
PROFESSOR: Exactly, yeah,
so what is going on here?
We have our tau-- one
of our tau effective--
or one of over lifetime
what we're measuring.
This is our effective
lifetime that we're measuring.
And we have one over tau.
Let's call it non-radiative.
So we have non-radiative
recombination mechanisms.
This comprises
Shockley-Read-Hall
recombination--
Auger recombination--
a bunch of different
recombination mechanisms.
And then we have one of our tau
radiative, which is essentially
this recombination
mechanism shown right here,
which is just the
band-to-band recombination.
So if you have
defects around, that
will lower the lifetime--
the non-radioactive lifetime.
If you have tons
and tons of defects,
the carriers will most likely
recombine through the defects
and not through the band-to-band
They will only recombine
with band-to-band
if there is nothing--
no other recombination
path left available to them.
It's a question of probability.
So if this is really,
really short--
non-radiative
recombination lifetime
is really, really short
because a defect density
is very, very large.
So the lifetime due to
non-radiative recombination
mechanisms is very short,
then that's tau effective
is also going to be very short.
And very few carriers are
going to recombine radiatively.
Conversely, if we have a very
clean material-- virtually
defect-free-- this
non-radiative lifetime
is then going to
be out the roof.
And now we're going
to be limited instead
by the radiative lifetime.
And so tau effective will be
more similar to radiative.
Now an interesting
thing happens when
you have a radiative
recombination event.
As the name would
suggest, it emits light.
And that light can be detected
by a CCD camera on your body.
So what you have-- there you go.
What you have right
here is a solar cell
device that is being
biased so current
is flowing into the device.
And now the map
what you're seeing
is indicative of radiative
recombination, why?
Because nearby the
cell, it's essentially
a very similar mechanism
or similar set up
to what we saw
right here where we
had bias voltage across
the device and imaging
not with an infrared camera,
but now with a camera matched
to the band gap energy.
This could be an indium
gallium arsenide camera
or say silicon camera, depending
on the precise band gap.
And you're imaging the
radiative recombination
as a function of xy
position across your wafer.
So these darker regions
here on the bottom
and on the right-- sorry
left-- the other right.
They indicate regions of lower
minority carrier diffusion
length.
Why?
Because there's less
radiative recombination
because this term
in those regions
is very, very small so that
there's not much radiative
recombination going on.
Whereas these other regions
here that appear brighter
have a lot more radiative
recombination going on.
Any questions about that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What fraction of
these radiative recombinations
are reabsorbed by the material?
Is it possible to figure
that out to a high degree
so you can get a quantitative
sense of how much is radiating?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
The question pertains
to photon recycling
and how many photons that
are radiatively emitted
get reabsorbed by the material.
That would depend on
the optical path length
inside of the material
of carriers being
generated in the material.
And you assume that
carrier generation
is fairly isotropic in
nature-- that there is not
any preferred direction unless
you have a dyed molecule that's
designed in a certain
way to emit light
in a certain orientation.
So you can assume
that the carrier
mission in most materials
as isotropic in nature.
And then it's just
a question of ray
tracing to figure out what
the optical path length is.
Compare that to the optical
absorption coefficient
in the material, and you get
your answer-- what fraction
of light gets reabsorbed.
All right, I can sense where
we're reaching threshold here
in terms of new
information gathered.
I'm just going to briefly go
over the Suns-Voc at the very
end .
And the Suns-Voc
technique is useful
as we saw during class because
as this paper right here by Ron
Sinton and Andres
Cuevas-- this one--
I know you definitely
have this one.
This paper essentially
describes the functioning
of the technique.
On page number two on the upper,
left-hand side, so figure 2,
we essentially have
the figure that
was determined on the screen
during the measurements.
So for those of you close
enough to the monitor
to actually watch the
measurement being taken
in the Suns-Voc, you
saw the light intensity
decaying exponentially.
So the light intensity
is a flash bulb, poof,
and decayed exponentially.
The open circuit voltage
measured by the device--
so you had this solar cell
device sitting on the platen
with a little probe
coming in and a 50 megaohm
resistor connected in series--
very little current flowing
through that external circuit.
But it's measuring the voltage.
So it's essentially
maintaining the solar cell
in open circuit
voltage conditions
while the flash is decaying.
And it's measuring the
open circuit voltage
across the device
at each illumination
intensity as the pulse decays.
So you can see the
time scale here
is on the order of a few
10s of milliseconds--
so a very fast measurement.
The electronics response
time has to be very fast.
It tells you what the RC time
constant of the circuit is.
And you can notice that the
voltage-- the open circuit
voltage decays linearly when the
illumination intensity decays
exponentially.
Why is that ?
AUDIENCE: Natural log.
PROFESSOR: This
is a natural log--
so what Joe showed to you
yesterday or on Thursday
in class is how the voltage
output of a solar cell
varies by illumination
intensity.
So there's a logarithmic
dependence there.
So that's why you take the log
of the exponentially decaying
light intensity and you obtain
a linear relation that's
the open circuit voltage
decline as a function of time.
So we can derive an
IV characteristic
by translating that open circuit
voltage into an implied bias
voltage.
And knowing the short circuit
current density up front
essentially by measuring it
by measuring the solar cell
device in a solar simulator,
we can obtain the short circuit
current density.
We pin both curves up here
at the measured short circuit
current density.
And then we plot both
curves out-- the IV curve
and the Suns-Voc curve.
Now the Suns-Voc curve
is similar to the IV
curve with only one difference.
There's no current or
very, very little current
flowing through the
external circuit, which
means there isn't any
real power flowing
through the external circuit,
which means if we go back
to our expression right here--
if we have no current flowing
through, that J
is equal to zero.
And now that R sub
S term disappears.
So we've come up
with a clever way
to drop all of our R sub
S out of that expression.
And the only thing that
matters essentially
is to some degree shunt.
But this is essentially
the highest IV curve
that one could possibly obtain
in the absence of series
resistance.
And that's what
you see right here.
That's this delta in
between your illuminated IV
curve-- what is measured
using the solar simulator--
and your Suns-Voc
curve, which is
measured in the absence
of series resistance.
Now this works well
with most materials.
If you have a very high
capacitance in your device,
you'll want to look very
carefully at this decay--
at the light intensity decay.
If your capacitance and
your device is very large,
it might actually flatten
out the voltage response.
So you want to make sure
that the time-- the RC time
constant of your device is
matched to the flash bulb decay
time.
That's just one word
of warning for those
working on high voltage
or organic materials.
Any questions on the
Sun-Voc measurement?
This gives you what's
called an implied IV curve.
And that is-- we could say in
the best case scenario what
you would get from
the solar cell
in the absence of any
series resistance losses.
AUDIENCE: The last
question-- Voc--
that's not a solar
simulator in any way is it?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: Is that important?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it is important.
It would be
different-- in essence,
it would be a different
current response
if you didn't have the
same exact solar spectrum.
Now, that's a very
important point.
If you're venturing outside
of, say, silicon-based devices,
and you're more sensitive
to the infrared or the UV,
you really want to make
sure that you measure
the intensity as a function of
wavelength output of that bulb.
Otherwise, you might be higher
or lower during the Suns-Voc
measurement.
For a silicon-based
device, the majority
falls within the
specified regime.
Down here-- actually right
here on this diagram--
that a little spot
right there-- that
is a small
calibration solar cell
of known short-circuit current
and open circuit voltage.
That's used to calibrate
for other silicon devices
if you're moving away from
silicon, that becomes an issue.
Correctable-- you can make
sure the spectral response--
or the spectral radiance
of that light source
and compare it to
the solar simulator
and do the normalization
accordingly.
Here's what I recommend.
With the last 15
minutes of class,
I wanted to catch
each of the teams
and talk about your
class projects just
to make sure that things
were rolling along.
I have feelers out to
some of the mentors who
haven't responded yet.
And so I just wanted to
touch base with each of you
for about three minutes just
make sure everything is rolling
along.